I have a few thoughts to share with our
new friend Central dawa in case you
missed it I had a debate with Central
dawa recently the topic was Muhammad in
the Bible the link is in the description
box before the debate multiple people
sent me a clip of central dawa promising
the um that he was going to end my
career and I made a promise to the
Muslim
umah that I will be the one to Barry
David wood I made I made every Muslim
that
Promise by the will of
Allah I will I will end David Wood's
career unfortunately for Central dawa
that didn't happen he broke his promise
to the umah he may feel bad about
breaking his promise but he shouldn't
for two reasons one he can always say
that he didn't mean he was going to end
my career in this debate Maybe meant
he's going to end my career 10 years
from now two the Quran allows Muslims to
break their promises in Surah
66:2 Allah declares Allah has already
ordained for you oh men the Absolution
from your Oaths Central dawa and I
discussed the historical background of
this verse in our debate Sun anai
3411 it was narrated from anus that the
messenger of Allah had a female slave
with whom he had intercourse but Aisha
and haa would not leave him alone until
he said that she was forbidden for him
then Allah the mighty and Sublime
revealed oh Prophet why do you forbid
for yourself that which Allah has
allowed to you until the end of the
verse this is about Central dawa's
Prophet Muhammad getting caught in his
wife H's bed with his slave girl Mary
the copt Muhammad was all to have sex
with his slave girls but his wives
didn't want it happening in their own
beds so they kept complaining until
Muhammad tried to appease them by
promising them that he would never touch
Mary the copt again Muhammad swore an
oath by Allah to his wives I will never
sleep with that slave girl again but
then he got a revelation telling him to
break his oath and to go back to having
sex with his slave girl that's the
historical background of the opening
verses of Surah 66 oh Prophet why do you
forbid for yourself that which Allah has
allowed to you seeking to please your
wives and Allah is of forgiving most
merciful Allah has already ordained for
you oh men the Absolution from your
Oaths and Allah is your maah lord or
master or protector and he is the
allower the all
wise so Allah has no problem with Muslim
men breaking their promises which means
Central dawa shouldn't be upset about
breaking his promise to the um but he
might also feel bad because of the
feedback people are saying David wood
mopped the floor with this little daa
boy this was one of the most one-sided
debates I've ever seen absolute brutal
Beatdown from David he had the other guy
looking like an ignorant clown LOL
Muslims are taking too many L's this
year give them a freaking break Central
was right about one thing this debate
was embarrassing dwood crushed him I
don't think I've ever seen such a
one-sided
debate this feedback could be
discouraging but I'm going to offer
Central dawa some
encouragement Central dawa you're young
and this was just one debate I don't
know how your other debates went but
this was only one debate I see you've
been challenging lots of people to
debate and that's a good way to build up
experience going to take some L's along
the way but if you learn from each
debate you'll get better and better in
addition to that you've got something
that a lot of dawa guys don't have
you've got courage how many dawa guys
are willing to do a debate about
Muhammad almost none of them they all
basically want to spend their time
attacking the Trinity they don't want to
go anywhere near Muhammad which is
strange if you think about it because if
they could show that Muhammad was a true
Prophet that would show that Islam is
true it would be the ultimate
daah but they're terrified of subjecting
Muhammad to any sort of scrutiny I
wonder why it's almost like they don't
believe they can actually defend him
but you Central daa to your credit chose
to debate Muhammad in the Bible we
should all give credit where it's due in
a sea of daa cowards Central daa stands
out because he's willing to defend
Muhammad so Central daa I encourage you
to keep defending your prophet and not
to be a coward like so many other daa
guys keep debating and keep
improving but as you debate I want you
to be aware of a few things and to ask
yourself a few
questions first you're copying Muhammad
hijabs chest thumping which really
impresses the Uma ask yourself why does
the new generation of dies rely so much
on me strong you weak me humiliates you
if Islam were true and if Muslims had
convincing arguments would they have to
rely on the sort of antics that you'd
expect from
cavemen second you're copying d Daniel
haku's tactic of misrepresenting sources
hoping that no one's going to bother
looking up those sources because if they
do they'll find that you're completely
misrepresenting them Daniel popularized
this method he would cite various
sources and studies claiming that they
prove his points eventually Mike Jones
from inspiring philosophy read the
sources and exposed Daniel for lying
about what's in those
sources but it's still a PO
daa tactic you go into a debate and you
say ah Professor Oingo has an article on
this and he agrees with me most people
of course have no clue what professor
opingo said so they think you're telling
the truth but eventually someone looks
up Professor ubing foo's article and
finds out that you're lying that's the
tactic and you've copied the tactic
Central daa so what I want you to ask
yourself is if Islam were true and if
Muslims had solid evidence for their
beliefs would they need to lie about
sources like
this third I noticed that you didn't use
any of the classic dawa passages about
Muhammad in the Bible Deuteronomy 18
Song of Solomon 5 John 14 and so on
instead you went with Psalm 45 Isaiah 28
Etc which means you're one of the daa
guys who tries to catch people off guard
with arguments they've never heard
before did didn't work but I want you to
ask
yourself if Islam were true and if
Muslims had good arguments wouldn't they
stick to these good arguments instead of
needing to change them every time to try
to catch people off
guard in other words the methods that
Muslims use to defend Islam are the
exact same methods that deceivers and
con artists use to dup gullible people
ask yourself does the truth need the
exact same methods that deceivers and
con artists use to dupe gullible
people did I need any of that what
arguments did I use did I try to catch
you off guard with some weird new
argument no I used the exact same
arguments I use whenever I discuss
Muhammad in the
Bible did I have to thump my chest not a
bit that I have to misrepresent sources
not
one why
why do you guys need tricks and
deception while the rest of us just need
arguments and
evidence let me know when you figure out
the answer to that question because
that'll be the day you're on your
way out of Islam
[Music]